I don't know what the heck is going on,
I don't know.
Normally, I get tired of it sooner and quit.
I'm not afraid of my parents I
'm not afraid of this monster
I'm afraid of me
Remember what's so scary that your body rejects it Image of
brushing away your
master's words
Telling your
wishes to
Yumiya You're a liar, so you're still a liar
[Music]
I
'll live on the
stairs.  I
saw my parents at the metropolitan government, they're all right
I'm in the middle of the harvest festival I have to
go home
to everyone So after
all, it's a chance to prove that even humans can stand next to everyone
, right?
In this festival that decides the strongest devil
[music] I
'll definitely win
[music]